If
you pay attention to the things that
shine forth because what you're seeing
is the reality instead of the map,
you're gaining access to the real
information that's in the world.
It's not pre packaged information
because that can be false.
It's the real information flowing up
from the ground of being and if you pay
attention to that,
it will help you move towards the goals
that you've already established for
yourself as a good citizen that are,
that are part of the inbuilt value
structure that you've adopted,
but at the same time it will do
something else.
It will lead you to transform the nature
of those goals because as you pursue the
thing that guides your interest and more
and more information is revealed.
Then by absorbing that information which
is learning,
essentially you build yourself into a
different person,
a stronger and more informed person and
a more,
a more intact person,
a person with more integrity and with
more straight than with more direction
and at the same time you differentiate
your map and so you're living more and
more in the real world.
So as you approach your specific goal,
even if it's a culturally conditioned
goal,
the learning that you do along the way
transforms you and it transforms the
nature of your goal.